History has not been kind to horses.
Many people talk about the 600,000
people killed in the American civil war,
but some overlook that the horse and
mule death toll is over 1 million.
In Victorian England.
It was not uncommon for trolleys and
factories to work horses until they
dropped dead,
sometimes in the middle of busy streets,
up and into the 20th century.
Horses brutally stood with a side by
side in war time and in civilian life
and even today where the average person
almost never interacts with horses in
their everyday lives.
We still see the horse constantly in art
and media for every culture with horses,
there's a different meaning applied to
them.
In Ancient Greece,
the animal was a sign of aspiration and
connection to the gods,
which we can see most clearly.
In Pegasus,
the Nordic people believed in horses for
day and night,
called her and factsy and skin foxy,
who traversed the land and sea and moved
with the wind.
Gandalf's horse shadow.
Fax was directly influenced by this
norse mythology,
but in this video,
I want to talk about a specific course
mythology,
the American version one deeply
ingrained in the modern American
conscious American cinema has
historically used the horse as a symbol
of status,
masculinity,
and mastery over nature,
and to explore this particular meaning
of the horse.
Historians don't have to look at ancient
paintings and stories like with older
civilizations.
We can actually very clearly see the
symbolism of horses in the movies and TV
have the last 100 years up in into the
current day.
So what do I mean by the Horse?
As a symbol of mastery,
the horse provides the perfect
opportunity to show mans control over
nature.
For one thing,
horses are very wild and unpredictable.
They're too large to keep in the home
like a dog and strong enough to easily
kill a human,
so they are a worthy opponent to
control.
Bronc riding reminds us of their
strength because they're genuinely
dangerous in certain contexts.
Despite these characteristics,
we still manage to tame them on a
massive scale.
We are able to control them,
send them into battle and use them as
tools more so than any other animal of
that size and unlike cattle or other
livestock,
they can easily be mounted.
There's nothing that shows mastery over
nature more than being on top of a large
wild beast directing it where you want
it to go.
Riding at a higher vantage point than
pedestrians to showcase my point.
How did the creators of the planet of
the apes series show that the monkeys
are dominating the planet,
are no longer simply wild animals and
are taking charge?
This simple image tells us everything we
need to know about how much the monkeys
are evolving and that's because of all
the meaning associated with riding a
horse.
Some of the earliest forms of cinema.
We can see how the horse human
relationship reinforce this horse riding
as a symbol of mastery in 18,
78,
Edward more bridge rigged.
Twenty four cameras on a racetrack with
trip wires that went off as a horse
galloped by.
He wanted to see if all four of the
horse's feet come off the ground at once
during Gallup.
Something that happens too quickly for
the human eye to see on its own.
This experiment tries to master the
movement of the Horse in a way more.
Bridge was taming the wild unknown
aspects of horseback riding and turning
them into something controllable by the
camera and by humans.
The camera man is a master of the world
around him capturing the horse as he
wants to make an part of nature.
No,
this experiment became one of the first
primitive forms of a motion picture and
it paved the way for cinema to contain
the wild nature of the horse.
From then on,
the horse in movies reflected a thing to
master a wild beasts to represent who
could control it and who couldn't.
These early ideals of horseback riding
found their way into Hollywood,
particularly in the western genre.
In these movies,
the horse showcases the mastery and
control of the typical western hero.
The horse is an extension of these
masterful writers who could effortlessly
handled their horses in dangerous
situations.
A classic example of control through
horseback riding comes from John Wayne
in stagecoach.
Throughout the movie,
the people writing the stage coach are
being controlled by others.
They either change plans to avoid an
Apache attack or because of the military
made them do so symbolically.
It makes sense that these two outside
forces would control the fate of the
stagecoach.
Both the Apache and the military are the
men actually riding on horseback.
Unlike the stage coach where the horses
are in front pulling the people behind
them.
John Wayne famously abandons the
stagecoach to ride one of the horses
himself,
giving the visual cue that he is now
taking control by becoming a man on a
horse.
In this final battle scene in the
military and stage,
coach members shoot the Apache off of
their horses,
indicating that now the Apache are no
longer in control.
There's actually a running gag and
American westerns where men are dragged
by horses.
Here we see a complete reversal of the
traditional roles because the horse is
in control instead of the man.
This trope is always reserved for the
characters not in control.
The ones without the swab and mastery of
the traditional American hero.
Either they can't control their horse or
they ride the horse in a bastardized
way,
maybe they're too short to ride the
horse themselves,
or they have to fake writing altogether.
You'll never see John Wayne riding a
horse in any way other than one that
shows cool manly control,
which brings up another key aspect of
horseback riding in American cinema.
In the real worlds,
horseback riding is one of the most
gender neutral competitions to exist
today in the Olympics.
Equestrian events or some of the few
where men and women compete against each
other,
but in American cinema,
that is not the case with some notable
exceptions.
Women on horses are few and far between,
especially at the peak of the western
genre.
This phenomenon is historically
accurate.
Since the men had the agency money and
land to own their own horses.
We can still feel this masculine
perception of horseback riding in modern
media.
It explains why this joke work.
Anything is possible when your man
smells like old spice and not a lady.
I'm on a horse.
The ideal man is one that rides a horse.
Any movie that puts women on a horse
usually challenges this norm of men on
horseback in Brokeback Mountain Lorraine
First Sees Jack while she's riding a
horse and he's on foot already
establishing a reversal of gender roles
on the horse.
She physically towers over him.
This role reversal continues when she
approaches him at the bar to hit on him
and act traditionally done by the man
throughout the movie.
Their positions in the marriage get
challenged.
She's the one operating the company with
the traditional office desk.
While he fights for control in the home,
the initial power dynamic of her on
horseback establishes masculinity in the
movie.
She rides the show horse,
showing her power,
wealth,
and control ball jackets thrown off a
bowl,
showing his lack of control,
and to hint at his non traditional male
role.
Westworld shows just how much the hosts
breaking the rules by having Dolores
Adaas Aisle,
female character become a horse riding
gunslinger with horses so closely
associated with masculinity,
control and power.
It's no surprise that characters will
also kill other people's horses to
assert dominance.
This power grab gets done most famously
in the godfather and the public enemy.
If a horse shows control,
killing the horse removes the control.
There are also racial undertones to
horseback riding.
It was illegal for black people to buy a
horse in many parts of the antebellum
south.
Such a loss seems unnecessary because
blind people did not have the money or
agency to own a horse in the first
place.
This redundancy implies that the law
existed as a symbolic gesture,
a reminder by white southerners that
black people should not have the status
and power associated with riding a
horse.
Django unchained touches on the racial
issues of horseback riding.
The simple act of being black into on a
horse challenges traditional portrayals
of men on horseback.
It's such a great movie because it lets
minority characters have the same cool
mastery and control that was originally
reserved for white men.
The movie perfectly showcases horseback
riding as a power dynamic.
Right in the first scene,
there's a power reversal where a horse
immobilizes a man,
the opposite of a man controlling the
horse.
Many times in the movie,
weaker characters are either thrown off
their horse or shot off their horse,
but never django.
When we watch the movie,
we never consciously observe who was
riding the horse well or not,
but these images play into subconscious
American ideas of mastery.
Through mastery of the horse,
we can feel how much more controlled
Django has compared to the other white
characters apart from Dr. King Shults,
who can command his horses that will add
fits.
We can feel how much more controlled
Django has compared to the other white
characters the KKK members can't see for
themselves,
so they let the horse take control.
I can't see you can't see.
So what all that matters is can the
fucking fate.
This KKK charge feels like a comedic
revision of a similar scene in the birth
of a nation filmed in 1915.
Dw Griffith portrays these KKK members
much differently than the easy to trick
idiots in Django Klansmen,
charged into town on a horseback to
rescue llc from the hands of black men
on screen by epic and skillful riding on
a horse transforms these klansmen from
an unruly mob into hero saving the day.
This movie uses horses to show the KKK
members as heroic end to end control,
and they disturbingly used their mastery
to attack and suppress black people in
the movie.
The cruelest irony in both the birth of
a nation and Django unchained is that
horses themselves are slaves.
They were tamed,
enforced to work historically for white
men in the cinematic sphere.
Controlling the horse shows if their
handler is a good master with Django as
a former slave.
His role as a horseback rider and master
is confusing since it's a slave
controlling a slave.
This unnatural relationship confuses
characters throughout the movie.
Django repeatedly does things a master
would do like whipping people and
manipulating people.
Do I sound like a fucking slave?
The horse symbolizes his new role as a
master of his domain,
but I want to go further.
I want to suggest that in some cases,
this symbolism of horse riding exists
past just the movies.
It bleeds into real life.
You know that it is special election day
and we do
expect to see a Senate candidate,
Roy Moore,
arriving by horseback to the polls.
Is it a coincidence that really more a
conservative Republican rode a horse to
the polls during his campaign in
Alabama?
I don't think so.
He rode that horse when he didn't have
to.
It was a symbolic gesture.
He was trying to evoke American
perceptions of the West ones of mastery
and control.
Now,
I'm not saying that riding a horse to
the polls is necessarily a bad thing,
lucy,
that men on horseback,
particularly when embodying old ideas of
the American cowboy evoke concepts of
domination and masculinity that are
inherently problematic in certain
contexts.
A state of emergency has been declared
in the US state of Virginia.
Jefferson were protesting the plan
removal of a confederate monument from a
city park.
Confederate.
Statues were taken down in New Orleans
after two years of court battles and a
heated public debate.
Protest.
Violence is extremely painful.
I was in tears yesterday to see that it
hurt.
It hurts.
I want American cars.
America has debated the removal of
confederate monuments around the country
for the last several years.
Opponents of the statues claimed that
these statues were not built as
memorials,
but rather to intimidate black people
and to reaffirm white supremacy.
One aspect of these statutes rarely
mentioned is the fact that these men are
very commonly on horseback.
It's one thing to have these people
standing,
but the fact that they are on horseback,
it gives them a certain mythological
authority like a John Wayne Western
hero,
a man on horseback symbolizes a man in
control,
a master of his domain,
a person of wealth and status physically
above the pedestrians around him,
but the mythologizing of these men
disguises a sinister history.
Though some Americans may look to these
statutes and be reminded of admire
herbal western heroes,
other Americans may look at them and see
a reminder of the men on horses who
fought to keep their ancestors in
chains.
After all,
the horse is itself a slave taken from
the wild and teams to work as a tool,
and the rider is his master,
whether you feel it consciously or not.
A confederate white man riding a horse
on a monument evokes slavery imagery and
a historical look at writing in American
cinema shows how the design of these
statutes makes them aggressive tools for
intimidation.
So what should we do about them?
Polls show America is torn on whether to
take them down,
but there's more to consider than simply
whether they should stay the same or
whether they should go away.
So there's a third option.
The third option is we engage our
contemporary artists of this time.
We have the mics sculptures that exist
in the communities that they live in.
We present those sculptures in the same
community squares where these Robert e
Lee sculptures exists.
We pull those least sculptures down from
the pedestal,
bring them at the same level as these
new contemporary works and we forced
these works to engage one another.
Richmond,
Virginia has five confederate leaders on
Monument Avenue,
including Jefferson Davis,
Robert e Dot Lee and stonewall Jackson.
But one other monument company falls
under the radar when talking about these
iconic centerpieces,
tennis legend,
Arthur Ashe also has his own statue on
Monument Avenue,
despite a much more design than his
confederate counterparts.
Their proposal of his statue sparked a
racial debate at the time of its
erection in the 19 nineties.
This statue is a step in the right
direction,
challenging monument avenue as a place
reserved for white confederate leaders.
Even so,
I think Richmond has an opportunity in
the current political climate to add
other more challenging monuments.
Monument Avenue Falls.
The tradition of white men in art
aristocrats in the 18th century commonly
commissioned portraits of themselves on
horseback to signify their importance,
wealth,
and power.
It's designed for domination.
It's,
it's a language designed to make the
sitter feel as though he could ride this
steve and control it with a pinky
controlled with the sheer will of his
mind.
It's a propaganda act
in response to these traditional
portraits artists can handle.
Wiley has a piece titled Napoleon
leading the Army over the Alps,
Wiley's piece recontextualizes,
the famous Napoleon painting by
replacing him with a black man in
contemporary clothing.
Critiquing the historical tradition of
ignoring the black cultural experience.
It crystallized something that I had
been thinking about for a very long
time,
which is that black men have been giving
very little in this world and that I as
an artist,
have the power and the potential and the
will to do something about it
because it's not just that.
These confederate heroes invoke slavery
imagery.
There's another opportunity with the
debate over these statues,
the opportunity to make heroes out of
people
well,
that have historically been put to the
side and we go into the front entrance
of the museum and there's that amazing
sculpture of Teddy Roosevelt out there.
You guys know which one I'm talking
about.
Teddy Roosevelt,
this in there with one hand on the horse
fall strong sleeves rolled up.
I don't know if he's bare chested,
but it kinda feels like it.
And on the left hand side of him is a
native American walking and on the right
hand side of him it was an African
American Walker.
And as we're moving up the stairs,
getting closer to the sculpture,
my oldest son who's nine says,
dad,
how come he gets to ride and they have
to walk.
I think an artist can handle wiley or
titus Kaphar could create a great
addition to monument avenue with a
statue that rethinks who gets to ride on
horseback.
So I'm not saying you should feel bad
for liking classic cowboy movies.
Some of those movies are amongst the
greats,
but I am saying that the horse rider
relationship deserves a closer look
because it reveals subtleties in our
media and how we can make more powerful
and challenging art.
Okay.
I'm done preaching this stuff.
I'll get off my high horse,
but there is one thing I won't get off
my high horse about.
As some of you might know,
I'm actually a software developer.
When I'm not making videos,
I'm writing code and logging in and out
of tons of applications and websites.
I keep all my passwords secure and out
of mind.
Using dashlane.
Dashlane is a secure and easy to use
password protection service with over 10
million users in the current tech
landscape.
It is definitely the best way to manage
the dozens of passwords you use on a
regular basis.
When you need to log into a site,
dashlane automatically adds your secure
password and it works on all phones and
computers,
iphone to Windows,
computers.
You can get these features for free or
dash lane premium gives you unlimited
password storage,
plus a vpn for every device you use and
darkweb monitoring to make sure your
data is not being bought and sold on the
dark web.
Click the link in the description or go
to [inaudible] dot com slash now you see
it to download it for free,
and if you want all those features,
you can use the coupon code.
Now you see it.
Thanks for watching.